[Music]
beyonce is back breaking the internet
dropping an unexpected visual for her
new song break my soul and what can we
say we are all ready for b's renaissance
era
we can't take all of beyonce's advice in
the house music mix but we can soak up
all of her striking looks in the newly
released video queen bee serves up
fierce fashion and glamour while belting
out upbeat vocals for her british vogue
feature
of course we got a glimpse of her photos
last month
but in true b fashion she never misses a
moment to surprise the beehive with the
creative visual
[Music]
[Music]
without warning beyonce dropped the
visual causing morning shows to scramble
just when you think she can't raise the
bar she does it again the today show
host joke producers didn't even have
time to add it to the top of the show
rundown
moments ago the music icon dropped a new
music video for her latest song break my
soul this happened minutes ago everybody
special
we didn't have time to write the copy
this is off the dome and the breaking
news was a topic of debate for gayle
king and her co-host over at cbs
mornings why didn't we leave with me
exactly shauna would have done our
executive racer would be fine with that
now we had a bit of an internal
discussion this guy this morning guys
about whether or not we should show that
cover image okay whether or not it was
too racy for morning tv so i'm gonna
take a poll what do we think okay or
it is racy but i think this this right
here it's racy but i think we should
show it
[Laughter]
just a day before the singer released
the album cover art giving us sexy disco
vibes here's beyonce in a silver bikini
on top of a horse of mirrored tiles like
a disco ball all on theme for the new
sound b is set to release on july 29th
racy or regal beyonce is going to go
above and beyond at least that's what
her mom tina knows lawson told us last
month she put two years of love into
this
many many nights all night working and
so i can't wait for the for the world to
hear it and we're back outside we set
you outside but you ain't that outside
worldwide hoodie with the mask outside
it's going to be motivation and
inspirational for all of us
um and something that will bring us back
to
you know being outside great club
music
great music to be on the dance floor and
feeling live and liberated and free
e.t also caught up with big frida who is
featured on break my soul she told us
what it was like working with beyonce
again
another great moment getting to hang out
with her at the studio space
and um
i you know i needed an asthma pump once
i left out of the building
[Applause]
[Music]
you